darla what's going on why are you asking
me
freddie freeman
this guy taught me everything i know
about being a dope superhero true story
you should get some pointers
from him what's going on my best bud
in the whole world and also new kids
that i'm meeting for the first time
would seem very cool uh i invited
another friend i hope
that's okay
according to sources close to the scene
an armed man has taken people hostage
on the second floor of that building the
situation is considered
active police say the man is wearing
body armor and should be considered
extremely dangerous no i think we just
found something we can agree on we are
following it closely though we're going
to go play outside now moment
about time someone listens to me stay
warm put your boats on
superman
hi everyone it's charlie they just
released shazam on digital you probably
heard the director talk about their
deleted scene with henry cavill superman
the original
ending of the movie there are now three
different endings that this movie had
including the one that you just saw with
superman walking up and just freaking
freddie out so we'll break it down
i'll also talk a little bit about what
just happened with the flash movie
because it was some really big news that
just dropped
we're doing a new imax ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a shazam or
superman comment on the video
i'll name a new winner at the end of
this alternate endings first
so there are two alternate versions of
the ending scene that you just saw
deleted scenes basically the first
deleted scene is the shazam family
seeing that there's a hostage crisis
downtown on the local news
and deciding to use their powers to save
the day is meant to be their first real
time acting as superheroes
after the events of the movie after they
put the seven deadly sins back in the
rock of eternity after dr savannah goes
to prison and has that scene with mr
mind
this is well after the events of the
movie like okay we're gonna be doing
this
all the time now at least locally
because even though the superman scene
as it exists
right now is shot so that you can't see
his head it's still meant to be the real
superman within the context of the dc
universe meaning that billy has met the
justice league and the justice league
including superman
know that there are now six kids little
kids mostly
crazy strong magical powers living in
philadelphia
if you were the justice league or even
just superman you would probably want to
keep taps on them because
his weakness is their power magic is his
big weakness
so i think the idea is that the billy
has met the justice league and they've
told him to take it slow
friendly neighborhood spider-man style
while he and the other shazam family the
shazamly are still figuring out their
powers and learning about the rock of
eternity
the reason that they tried this version
of the ending obviously wound up
deleting it because they decided the
superman cameo one wound up being better
is because originally there was a
separate henry cavill superman scene
that didn't seem like they were going to
be able to shoot so during the
commentary track of the movie the
director said that he needed to come up
with anything oh my god we have to have
an ending for this movie but he just
decided that
this wasn't quite the one that he was
looking for so that's why it wound up
being a big deleted scene
the other deleted scene is the original
ending as they intended it the very
first one that they had planned with
superman
full on it was a much longer version of
the superman scene that you saw in the
actual theatrical cut
the deleted scene the alternate ending
with superman was going to be henry
cavill superman walking into the
lunchroom on
cue and sitting down fully in frame next
to freddy at the table so that you could
actually see that it was him
but he didn't have any big dialogue
there weren't any lies he just sat down
when freddy craps his pants and makes
that yelp sound of extreme surprise
originally he had a bunch of lines where
he starts freaking out and it was a much
longer version of him going oh my god i
have so many questions
and just laying into superman like a
superman fanboy at a convention meet and
greet
the reason why henry cavill didn't wind
up in the theatrical cut of the movie
that original ending was because he was
held up filming mustache impossible
fallout
originally what was supposed to happen
is that mission impossible was supposed
to finish their filming
by the time that they started filming
the shazam movie but tom cruise broke
his leg doing that crazy building jump
stunt
and they had to delay filming on mission
impossible for eight
weeks so when they came back to finish
filming mission impossible they were
already ready to film henry cavill's
superman scene for the shazam
ending so that's why they had to come up
with a completely different version of
the scene
the justice league reshoots didn't get
in the way those were actually finished
by the time shazam started shooting so
if you want to blame someone for henry
cavill not being in the shazam movie
blame tom cruise's broken leg the reason
why they couldn't get henry cavill in
during the shazam
reshoots which happened way later at the
end of 2018
was that by the time they had started
doing those he was full-on
shooting the witcher series for netflix
they're actually dropping a trailer for
that in a couple weeks at comic-con so
we'll be talking about witcher stuff in
a couple weeks
normally if there's a small cameo scene
like that it's a lot easier to schedule
around a really big actor's other
projects because they're usually filming
big movies all year long they're booked
years and years in advance
but it just wound up being the perfect
storm between mustache and possible
justice league reshoots in the witcher
series so that's why you didn't see
henry
cavill in the shazam movie so don't be
surprised if you see way bigger cameos
in the next shazam movie whatever they
call the sequel
justice league characters like wonder
woman and superman because zachary levi
did say that they were trying to get a
wonder woman cameo in the first shazam
movie but by the time they started
working on that gal gadot was also busy
doing other stuff
biggest cameo in the shazam sequel
probably going to be the rock's black
adam though because the black adam movie
is actually going to premiere
before the shazam sequel so we'll have
already met that character and
know how he works so it would make sense
that they start to try to get him into
the shazam movies by that time
moving into the flash movie news you
probably heard that they revealed they
just
hired a new director who's actually a
horror director and a new writer they
have not
fired ezra miller surprisingly that was
the one thing i felt like was going to
happen but they did throw
out the script that he was working on
with grant morrison
what happened was is that the directors
of the movie were going to be the
writers from spider-man homecoming
they wanted to do a lighter movie a la
back to the future
ezra miller wanted to do a darker movie
more like comic book flashpoint and he
wanted to do more multiverse stuff
so they had a couple competing versions
of the movie warner brothers threw out
both of those versions so the writers of
spider-man homecoming
left the project they hired the director
of it
chapter 2 so they hired a horror
director meaning that they want to go
with a darker tone flash movie but they
hired the
writer of the birds of prey movie and
the bumble me movie so just
kind of balance that idea because
bumblebee was not a dark film and birds
of prey even though it's obviously a
little bit darker
doesn't sound like it's going to be
suicide squad level dark the interesting
thing though is is that people who have
actually been seeing birds of prey
footage say that it's a pretty badass
film
so if it's getting so much praise behind
the scenes you would think that they
wouldn't want to show it teaser off but
i think
they're probably going to wait till
october to show the first trailer from
that
when the joker movie premieres because
remember we still have that rated r
todd phillips joker movie with joaquin
phoenix coming up later this year so
there'll be more footage for that before
we see the birds of prey footage
but the last we heard about the flash
movie is that they wanted to introduce
the multiverse and even though it would
probably still be a version of
flashpoint it'll still be relatively
self-contained to just
flash comic book characters maybe minor
cameo or two but the whole thing now is
they're trying to separate the dc movies
even though they're technically still
connected
this is the last thing that ezra miller
said about them introducing
dc multiverse though which did kind of
get me excited even though he sounds
like he just took a whole bunch of drugs
before he did this interview
we're talking about sparking a whole new
universe which is it's not just the dc
it's multiverse it's also it's the
speedster multiverse
and the speedsters are the ones who
connect all of the disparate pieces of
it because marvel is the universe right
it's just
one world and all the same characters in
it dc is a multiverse
all these different stories with
different realities different characters
and versions of characters
and the speedsters are the ones who move
through it all they're like the
the connecting bridge between all these
different collaged parts
and so i'm really delighted at how
focused um everyone is on getting it
just right and i'm really devoted to
that as well and i
honestly like we won't make the film
unless it's going to be
this consummate beautiful offering to
the
to the fans and to everybody i mean
we're just going to make a fantastic
view but we're really focused on making
it this like
super gift to dc fans couple minor
issues with that interview he does kind
of get things wrong about how the marvel
multiverse works they've already kind of
done multiverse in the doctor strange
movie so we'll just pretend like he
hasn't seen
all the marvel movies yet i know you're
all wondering about when the next actual
man of steel movie
is going to happen like i said i did a
video about how jj abrams has been
basically moving his company into warner
brothers with this big 500 million
dollar deal
they're basically paying jj abrams 500
million dollars to develop movies and
television shows exclusively for warner
brothers now
that deal is so big it's probably going
to take the rest of the year to close
that which is probably why you won't
hear anything
about that at comic-con and dc movies
are just kind of skipping comic-con in
general
odds are pretty good that he'll wind up
doing the green lantern core movie or
he'll wind up doing a man of steel
sequel
he'll probably go for green lantern i
think that actually needs more attention
than man of steel and maybe you just do
a superman cameo during that
because we have had a couple really
great superman films in the last
20 30 years but we have not had a good
green lantern movie yet
fun easter egg 2 the director of mission
impossible christopher mcquarrie and
henry cavill actually
pitched green lantern and superman
movies to warner brothers a little while
ago
but he actually said the director said
that they did not go for it or they did
not move forward with his idea for a
green lantern movie or for a man of
steel sequel
he never explained what the plot of
those movies were supposed to be so it's
just open to speculation as to what
those might have looked like but the way
he tells it now is that he does not
expect to do any kind of superhero movie
in the future so whatever that idea was
it sounds like it's come and gone but if
there's any really big dc movie news
happening around comic con i will do a
video for it but i'm not expecting any
big trailers
the big news though is is marvel just
announced they're doing a 90-minute
haul h comic con panel with kevin feige
that means they're probably going to
show off footage for a couple films
maybe some concept art
and announce their phase 4 schedule or
at least the next four years or so worth
of movies
including spider-man 3. so i will talk
about all that stuff in a separate video
but if you have any big questions that
you want me to make bonus videos about
just let me know in the comments
and congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last big video comical
cosmetic please email me on the about
page of my channel so i can get your
details
click here for my spiderman far from
home easter eggs and post credit scene
videos
and click here for that new shazam black
adam
you